MSRP is just so immersive really a great
energy of people who love to learn it
makes you grow as a person as a
scientist and as a student it's exciting
to do research because you don't always
know what you're gonna get
this summer I'm looking at how do the
education decisions made by families and
students in secondary school affect
economic development as a whole my
project consists on creating a device
that simulates bring my commotion I've
been giving a lot of independence to
work on my ideas and how I want to do
things I'm modeling the horizontal
movement of a droplet on a vertically
vibrating fluid path and an exhibits
behavior similar to quantum mechanics
some of them fly off because the force
decreases as the radius increases this
was something I wanted to explore and
something I wanted to do and I wasn't
trying to earn a grade I was trying to
discover something
chemistry just kind of fell into my lap
as a way where I can do all the deep
thinking that I like to do we are
working with Tripta scene it's really
useful for things like filtering gas
through different particles like carbon
monoxide and just bad things like that
but you don't want people to breathe in
she's made a number of polymers and has
really some great results and I'm sure
she's gonna end up on a publication I'd
like the idea of doing something that no
one's ever done before that you are able
to say is yours I'm not you going to
hear it through and through and I like
my circus and I like my design
a lot of the electronics that are on the
market today are silicon based and the
problem using silicon based electronics
as sensors within the body is that
silicon degrades in the body graphene is
just pure carbon one atom thick very
light transparent and you can have a
sensitive to anything research is fun
it's a journey I feel like because it's
never just one straight path there's
always challenges that come up there's
all these things you can't explain
people are really here to help you they
want you to succeed and they're here to
support you I'm actually it's very
collaborative and you can branch out
from your research and ask questions
from other people and get help I love
that about this place they definitely
want to get a PC I love chemistry as an
undergrad it's very important to have
research experience if you're applying
to graduate institutions because what I
found out you know over the past year
was that graduate education is primarily
research faculty here are really
available for their summer students is
not just a laboratory research program
they educate the students about all
aspects of becoming a professional in
science and engineering these tests
collected data from the medial
prefrontal cortex each week a group from
the MSRP program gets a faculty paper
and it's probably not going to be
something in your field so you get one
week to understand the paper and present
it and we can study how the brain is
passing information while it's actually
just behaving in a normal setting
purpose of this whole involve weekly
presentation is to open people's minds
up to other fields having the present
the paper you really challenge to
understand what's going on and how they
did their methods and what research is
like in other fields I'm so impressed by
how well my peers are able to break down
these really difficult concepts for
someone who hasn't taken much science in
college we all get stressed but we all
like to have fun this last weekend we
went to Martha's Vineyard it was a
really nice day to just relax and enjoy
the beach and enjoy just not having to
worry about things that are back in the
lab we have a weekend where we are
volunteering my MSRP cohorts and I went
over to the Cambridge Children's Center
my group went to the Food Bank of Boston
it was great to be able to give back to
our community
it's a very motivating feeling just to
see how far you progress comparing where
I am now to my first couple of weeks is
really just leaps and bounds I know that
it's really important that more students
are given these kind of opportunities to
do research explore research related
careers it's just been really great to
get that self-confidence but you might
not have been there in the past and it's
also just made me a lot more focus I
think to be a researcher you need two
things you really need to be passionate
about the topic you're working on and
the most important thing is to be
patient just results don't come in an
hour and they maybe take months or years
I think we were placed outside of our
comfort zone that's when we really grow
in MSRP loves to throw you outside of
your comfort zone but it's in a great
way in a positive way
you